Martin scors seesi is one of the most
recognizable names in the history of
Cinema I mean this guy's been pumping
out hits for 50 years and by hits I
don't just mean critical Darlings or box
office smashes although most of his
movies are those things I'm talking
about groundbreaking film making movies
that people still reference watch and
hold in high regard to this day I mean
this list could very well be the top 25
films of his career considering the fact
that certified fresh Classics like Cape
Fear casino and Wolf of Wall Street
don't even s sniff the top 10 and by the
way number 10 is at 89% certified fresh
on the Tomato Meter number 10 so take
your places as we roll cameras on the 10
best scorsi movies ranked by Tomato
Meter on Rotten Tomatoes
countdown number 10 the king of comedy
this 1983 satirical black comedy marked
the director's fifth collab with Robert
dairo who started alongside Jerry Lewis
and Sandra burnhard exploring themes
like celebrity worship and media culture
in America Robert plays a struggling
wannabe comedian named roer who becomes
obsessed with a successful TV host and
comedian played by Lewis now roer goes
to the extreme of abducting this man
that he's been stalking in hopes of
earning a spot on his TV show will you
please give your warmest welcome to the
newest king of comedy rert
pupkin
good evening ladies and
gentlemen my name is Rupert puppet I was
born in clion New Jersey which was
not dairo actually studied standups for
months in preparation for this part and
declined a lunch with this co-star Lewis
because Bob's character was actually
supposed to be ready to kill Jerry's
character for his big chance and he
didn't really want to mess with that
Vibe I mean I'd say that's probably one
of the only acceptable reasons to flake
out on lunch now scorsi who has a habit
of making C in his movies appears as a
TV director but also included his
parents and sister in a couple small
parts along with members of The Clash I
mean how does one get on the adoption
list of this family Number Nine Taxi
Driver director scorsi and star dairo
were coming off the highly acclaimed
Mean Streets from 73 so the pressure was
on for this one and they certainly
delivered filming took place in New York
City during a summer heat wave and a
sanitation strike while actors actually
took pay cuts to help get it made dairo
prepared for his role by working as a
cab driver late at night in New York
City and also I guess by talking to
himself in the mirror you talking to
me you talking to
me you're talking to
me then who the hell else are you
talking talking to me iconic I know that
word is so overused but it truly applies
here Taxi Driver also featured a
12-year-old jod Foster who underwent
psychological testing and met with a
psychiatrist to ensure that she wouldn't
be emotionally scarred by the role her
older sister Connie Foster was 19 at the
time and actually served as Jody's body
double for the more racy scenes and due
to that casting and the film's graphic
violence it nearly earned an X rating
until scorsi desaturated the color in
the final shootout scene just to get it
bumped to an R fascinating number eight
Alice doesn't live here
anymore coming early in scorsi feature
film career this movie remains a bit of
an outlier still to this day considering
it's a romantic dramedy that focuses on
a female lead and that lead is Ellen
Burston who won an Oscar for this role
as a widow who takes her tween son on a
road trip across the southwestern United
States to try and find a better life
than the one that they were
living do something about that kid turn
that thing
down I'm sorry
Don and now keep it off you're going to
drive us death do you want me to have a
fight with them huh how are we supposed
to have a meaningful family relationship
when he's on the verge of killing you
half the time Ellen later said that
working with a young Marty was quote one
of the best experiences she ever had in
Hollywood which is pretty High Praise
from a legend and fun fact the movie
actually inspired the long running CBS
sitcom Alice which had one actor Vic
tayac who plays Mel the diner owner
reprises role from the film number seven
The
Departed this crime Thriller is both a
remake of the 2002 Hong Kong film
infernal Affairs and is Loosely based on
the real life Boston Winter Hill Gang
and Crime Boss Whitey buer it could have
one of the best male casts in movies
like ever with Jack Nicholson Leonardo
DiCaprio Matt Damon Marky Mark Alec
Baldwin Martin Sheen you get it and of
course Vera figa is also amazing in this
now story wise there's both a rat inside
the criminal organization and an
informant inside the police force and
it's basically a race to see who can
flush one or the other route and let's
just say that rats can be pretty
annoying to some people I got this
rat annoying
keing
right and it brings up
questions you know see Bill like you're
the new
guy
girlfriend
why don't you stay in the bar that night
I got your
numbers clearly not a big fan of rats
now Brad Pit was actually supposed to
play opposite Leo but he decided that a
younger actor should do it so they got
Matt Damon and Brad Pit stayed on as a
producer and good thing because this
movie won Best Picture and best director
for scori at the Oscars making it
Marty's first and only Academy Award um
what make it make sense number six
Raging
Bull this biographical Sports drama is
based on boxing champ Jake lat's 1970
Memoir with Robert dairo starring as the
boxer now it covers his rise and fall in
the world of boxing that was fueled by
rage and jealousy I was surprised to
find out that scorsi actually turned
this one down a bunch of times mostly
because he's not a big boxing or Sports
guy it wasn't until a near deadly drug
overdose that the director began to
identify with the story and realized
that the boxing ring can be an allegory
for any in
life Robson hurting
lurting have Lam on Street holding
on well certainly that was one of the
most damaging evidences of punching that
you have seen in recent years come
[Applause]
on ouch along with taking a beating or
at least sitting in a makeup chair to
get that appearance dairo gained around
60 lbs to play Jake in his later years
and it all paid off cuz Bob won an Oscar
for his efforts although it lost out on
the best picture trophy it was gradually
recognized as arguably the best films of
the80s and considered possibly one of
the best ever crazy how that happens wow
my friends we are halfway to number one
for those of you with short-term memory
loss I feel you here is a recap number
10 was the king of comedy number nine
was taxi driver number eight was Alice
doesn't live here anymore number seven
The Departed and number six was Raging
Bull some pretty iconic ones have
already been checked off so what exactly
is left well I'm going to go ahead and
let you know in three two
one number five killers of the flower
moon now this Western crime drama and
the most recent movie on this list is
based on the 2017 novel of the same name
by David Gran it tells the story of a
series of murders in the oage nation of
Oklahoma in the 1920s after oil was
found on tribal land now this Mark scor
say he's sixth time working with
Leonardo DiCaprio and 10th with Robert
dairo although get this it's actually
the first feature film with all three of
them together those two lead a cast that
also includes Lily Gladstone Jesse plens
John Lithgow and Brendan
[Music]
Fraser
glad Sona said that the input of the
oage nation ended up greatly changing
scor's original vision of the film for
the better and it's not just the critics
who like this one with an audience score
at 85% the general Vibe for movie goers
is that they love the acting
cinematography and the powerful Story
the people have spoken number four
Hugo a very Far Cry from the dark and
gritty fair that scors sayi is known for
this adventure drama follows an orphan
boy who lives in the walls of a 1930s
Paris train station now while his job is
maintaining the station's clocks his
Focus becomes to solve the mystery of an
automaton that his late father left him
it's got a stellar cast that includes
Jude Law Ben Kingsley Khloe Grace
morrettes and Asa Butterfield is the boy
named
[Music]
Hugo the
this was scors say's first 3D film which
intrigued him because he felt the actors
were even more upfront emotionally with
even their slightest moves more
noticeable despite a season High a 11
Oscar nominations and a critics
consensus that calls it quote an
extravagant elegant fantasy Hugo was
considered a box office flop mostly
because it was up against Disney's The
Muppets and a Twilight movie but hey it
made its way onto this list and what
more do you really need number three
Good
Fellas based on the 1985 non-fiction
book wise guy by Nicholas py who
co-wrote the screenplay with scorsi this
1990 film Chronicles the rise and fall
of mob associate Henry Hill from 1955 to
980 with Ray Leota as Henry he was
joined by Robert dairo and Joe peshi who
won an Oscar for the part by the way and
the three of them would meet with
Nicholas to actually get more info
Beyond what's in his book to help their
performances I mean I personally love to
ask him how to walk through a restaurant
when you're in the mob and look like a
badass and then there was P the killer
who was Sally balls' brother took care
of that thing
for and you had Nikki eyes what's up guy
and Mikey franches saw that guy yeah I
want to see him and Jimmy Two Times who
got that nickname because he said
everything twice like I'm GNA go get the
papers get the
P scori was actually not interested in
doing another mobster movie surprisingly
but ended up being drawn to pgi's book
Because of its honest portrayal of
gangsters now when it came to filming
Martin would let the actors ad lib
during rehearsals and then take lines
that he liked from those and put them
back into the script for final filming
not a bad way to piece together what
would become one of the most iconic
films ever made in the gangster genre or
just ever and I'm not trying to be funny
like a clown number two mean
streets now you could almost call this
one 1B on our list since it technically
has the same Tomato Meter score just
with a slightly lower audience score
than our number one this wasn't scors
sei's first feature but it was one of
the first that he really had a hand in
when it comes to story and writing and
not only did it help put him on the map
after being a critical and Commercial
Success it was actually the first ever
collaboration between him and Robert
dairo I think that deserves a slow
clap where's the rest yeah where's the
rest well I bought a few rounds of
drinks over here while I was waiting you
know I
mean Tony says my credit ain't no good
no
more Marty was actually looking to make
a film inspired by his own experiences
and he leaned on things that he
witnessed during his childhood growing
up in Little Italy in New York City now
Harvey kitel also stars in Mean Streets
and the critics call it a quote powerful
tale of urban sin and guilt which is
also a good way to describe my past
weekend number one the
Irishman based on the biography of Frank
the Irishman Sheron by Charles Brandt
this movie stars alpacino as Jimmy hafa
and Robert dairo as his friend and
alleged murderer Hitman Frank Sharon it
is a pretty great pair to be around I'm
sure unless of course you're late for a
meeting you're late what you're
late and it was traffic yeah it's
traffic wasn't it traffic you give me
traff traffic what do you what do you
want from us it was bumper bum yeah yeah
no no it's it's bad you know
traffic I never waited for anyone who
was late more than 10 minutes in my life
and while this was the ninth team up for
dairo and scorsi it was shockingly the
first time the director worked with
Pacino he also got Joe PES out of
semi-retirement to get back in front of
the camera thank the universe and Harvey
kitel Anna pacin Bobby canaval Jesse
plens and Ray Romano have supporting
roles I mean talk about an All-Star team
the Irishman makes heavy use of daging
CGI so the Stars could play younger
versions of their characters for part of
the movie which actually caused the
budget to keep going up but the question
is did it work well it's on this list as
number one so I guess I'd say so well
friends whether you came for the great
stories terrific acting or glorious
eyebrows good times were had I mean
seriously Martin scorsi has the best
eyebrows for more on all these movies
that we discussed today be sure to hit
up rotten tomatoes.com thanks for
checking out today's list until next
time I'm Nas Perez and we'll see you
back here for more Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
countdown
n